[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
opening statements are presented as a
former olympic athlete stands trial for
attempted murder his choice to get a gun
a pink and black nine-millimeter handgun
to point that gun at lauren and pull the
trigger twice and then
to turn it on rob and pull the trigger
again my client is not guilty
at the time of the shooting my client
feared for his life plus the state could
soon rest its case as a former icu
doctor stands trial for patient murder
and i'll look behind the curtain into
the alleged sarah lawrence college cult
please leave i don't want to throw
myself away because i love you and i
want to stay with you
but first the slap scene around the
world oh richard
oh wow
will comedian chris rock press charges
against will smith what happened at last
weekend's academy awards law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer terry austin has the
day off comedian chris rock will not
press charges following an academy
awards smackdown on sunday when actor
will smith slapped him across the face
this just moments after rock made a joke
at the expense of smith's wife jada
pinkett smith
jada i love you g.i jane 2 can't wait to
see it all right
it's javazone that was a nice one okay
i'm out here oh richard
oh wow
wow
[Applause]
will smith
the slap aired live sunday night during
the 94th annual academy awards as rock
went to present an award he made a joke
about the 1997 movie gi jane in which
actress demi moore sports a shaved head
he joked that actress jaded pinkett
smith the wife of will smith would
appear in the movie sequel after that
smith walked onto the stage and slapped
chris rock though producers cut the
audio of the live broadcast reporters in
the room noted smith yelled out at rock
to quote keep his wife's name out of
your mouth all this comes after jaded
pinkett smith revealed to fans that she
suffers from alopecia and now struggles
to grow hair on her head less than an
hour after the altercation smith
delivered a tear-felt acceptance speech
after winning the best actor oscar for
his work in the movie king richard the
los angeles police department also
released a statement saying it was aware
of the incident at the academy awards
but that rock has declined to file a
police report it goes on to say quote if
the involved party desires a police
report at a later date lapd will be
available to complete an investigative
report
the academy says it will now launch a
formal review into the slap
joining us today is law and crime legal
analyst matthew mangino and criminal
defense attorney julie rendellman julie
does chris rock even need to press
charges doesn't the video kind of say it
all and if he does or doesn't are we
gonna expect these actors and actresses
to get interviewed
so technically he doesn't need to be the
one who press charges i mean keep in
mind when there's a homicide you don't
have that person pressing charges it's
the state of california that determines
whether charges exist with that said
there's no way in the world they're
going forward with the case against will
smith unless chris rock decides that he
wants to do that it is a battery
everyone saw it there's no question i
don't think anyone's going to need to be
interviewed i don't think beyonce is
going to be interviewed in terms of what
she saw because we all saw it but i
don't think based on the fact that chris
rock seems to not want to go there keep
in mind he may say by the way this was
just a joke this wasn't real um so
there's no chance it's going forward all
right i'm glad you went to julie because
this this leads me into matthew's
questions there's still a debate as to
whether or not this was staged or or or
real what do you think
well there's a
thin line between uh reality and
make-believe especially when you're in
hollywood uh but uh it would be a
stretch to think that will smith would
want to have to generate some publicity
when he's moments away from uh winning
an academy award uh so yeah i mean
the line has been blurred
and there's no question about that but
but why would you stage something like
this to generate publicity that might
even overshadow the fact that you're
going to win the best actor award it
doesn't it doesn't doesn't add up yeah i
mean and it kind of has overshadowed his
award because he did win an award today
but most people including us are talking
about this slap so we'll see how it
plays out as this story unravels
continuing on in celebrity news actor
alec baldwin returns back to work for
the first time since the deadly shooting
on the set of the ill-fated movie rust
filming for the movie russ was halted
last october as investigators began to
piece together what happened to cause
the death of cinematographer helena
hutchins as law on crime daily reported
baldwin was holding the weapon as it
fired killing hutchins and injuring
director joel souza
since then baldwin has maintained he did
not fire the weapon and is cooperating
with the investigation this comes as
hutchins family files a wrongful death
lawsuit against baldwin other producers
and crew members involved with the
production
attorneys for the hutchins family say
they expect the lawsuit to go to trial
within the next two years
still ahead on law and crime daily the
state is expected to soon rest its case
as one-time icu doctor stands trial for
murder but first another alleged cult
member takes the stand in the sarah
lawrence college cult federal trial
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back another alleged victim
takes the stand and then trial for
accused sarah lawrence sex cult leader
lawrence ray felicia rosario and her
siblings are three of the many alleged
cult members ray recruited from his
daughter's group of college friends ray
faces several federal charges including
racketeering sex trafficking and money
laundering all stemming from alleged
crimes over the last decade so far the
jury has heard from the prosecution's
key witness claudia jewry who testified
of ray's alleged abuse and manipulation
she claims rave forced her into
prostitution several court exhibits have
been released sharing more insight as to
what was going on inside the courtroom
one released over the weekend gives us a
closer look at life inside the alleged
cult
are you video over here
can we go inside the house please
please come on
come on ladies stop hurting me i'm not
hurting them you're punching me let's go
inside the house please yeah you're
gonna get hurt yourself please let's go
inside the house i want my phone i want
my life back together come on let's go
inside stop pinching me let's go inside
the house larry
you're
[Music]
law and crimes adam classified is
covering this case from inside the
courtroom he's heard firsthand the
testimony of lois ray's alleged victims
we are hearing from his third alleged
victim it's felicia rosario the first
alleged victim that we heard from was
santos rosario he was a sarah lawrence
student
and felicia rosario is his sister now
she is not one of the witnesses to the
sex trafficking count but according to
her testimony she easily could have been
because larry ray asked her to be an
escort in order to pay back for her
alleged offenses against him she didn't
do it but her testimony eerily rhymes
with that of claudia drury who said that
he would urge these students essentially
to go farther and farther
in what he sold as this journey of
sexual liberation it would eventually
get more and more extreme
until in this case he allegedly tried to
pressure her into becoming an escort we
know that in the
last alleged victim that we heard from
that actually happened here it stopped
short of just that
let's bring back criminal defense
attorney julie reynolds and legal
analyst matthew mangino as we get a
greater look into this college cult
julie gruesome details must be weighing
heavily on the jury but how does the
government turn that into a guilty
verdict here
i think they've already turned it into a
guilty verdict i got it i gotta tell you
i think the evidence has been absolutely
overwhelming remember it's not the
typical kind of evidence you hear
because any time there's that cult-like
behavior there's manipulation there's
taking advantage of specifically in this
case young women and men that sometimes
are mentally vulnerable and you're
basically watching it happen and and i
think there's no question that the
prosecutor has weaved for the jury a
clear understanding of the manipulation
this defendant was able to take with
each and every one of the individuals um
i think the question is what what can
the defense bounce back with other than
questioning certain credibility of the
witnesses which i don't think is going
to get them where they need to be in
terms of an acquittal yeah i know it's a
bad phrase to say but a lot of defense
attorneys will look at this trial and
say this just looks like a long plea
deal but matthew the more and more i
hear about this college cult the more i
ask where was the faculty and the people
watching the dorms can the college be on
the hook for what allegedly happened to
these victims
well that's a great question brian and
and i think that certainly it's going to
be tested um you know i have uh two
children in college right now and i'm
astonished that something like this
could happen
at a college uh where an adult is is
basically in the dorm uh you know
cultivating students manipulating
students how could this go on how could
it not be discovered i i think it's
certainly something that's going to be
scrutinized it's something that's going
to be tested
and ultimately sarah lawrence callers
might find themselves on the other side
of a lawsuit
and a successful lawsuit that especially
as a lot of these videos come to light
and everyone's kind of seeing how
horrible this was if that does happen of
course law and crime daily will have you
covered for those updates and in novato
police say a suspect is now in custody
in connection to the disappearance of 18
year old naomi irion but right now
irion's whereabouts are still unknown
investigators say 41 year old troy
driver was arrested on friday he's being
charged with kidnapping after officials
say he approached irion's car in a
walmart parking lot outside of reno
nevada they say he later drove off with
erion inside irion's vehicle was found
abandoned near the same walmart just
days later police say erion was active
on social media leading up to her
disappearance her family says she was
waiting in the parking lot for a shuttle
to her nearby job if you have any
information about irion's disappearance
please call the number on your screen
coming up on law and crime daily from
the olympics to attempted murder charges
we hear opening statements in the trial
of michael barrison plus after weeks of
testimony the state may soon rest its
case in the trial of william husso
welcome back to law and crime daily the
state is expected to rest soon in the
case of ohio versus william hussell a
former icu physician on trial for the
deaths of over a dozen patients
prosecutors say whosoever ordered
excessive doses of fentanyl to patients
which led to their deaths but his
defense argues the former doctor was
simply giving end-of-life comfort care
jurors so far have heard from husel's
former co-workers and several family
members of his alleged victims monday
began the sixth week of trial which
started out with arguments between the
prosecution and defense over a witness
appearing to tamper with evidence while
on the stand testimony then continued
with a former mount carmel nurse and two
alleged victims family members in fact
one patient's son was shocked to learn
his father was on life support
we were advised that his he was in total
organ failure
and
that
it sounded kind of crazy to us but the
life support meds were actually
uh
killing him okay makes a lot of sense
was a decision made to withdraw care
from your dad
uh
yes why did you all make the decision
you did
well we were told uh several times that
that
they needed to do that if we didn't want
him to be kept alive uh
by life support we asked
when did this when was he autumn
suddenly on life support
was we were just shocked that now he's
on life support we thought he was
waiting on surgery
criminal defense attorney julie
reynoldman and legal analyst matthew
mangino let's bring him back in here so
we can look back at the prosecution's
case and ahead of what might be the
defense's case julie has the prosecution
made the line between murder and comfort
care far enough for a conviction or do
you think more is needed before the
prosecution rests
so it's a great question and an
impossible question to answer and the
reason i say it's always interesting
when you have in this case 14 victims
because inevitably you start to think
well how can it be it
on you you know how could it be a shock
that if there's 14 there must be some
basis for for what happened i think what
some of the jurors are going to sit
there and say to themselves
would i ever ever put my family member
in the care of this defendant and the
answer is no they have to ask themselves
why and if it's why because they believe
beyond a reasonable doubt that his care
went beyond care and went to murder then
he's guilty the defense still has some
room in there um to bring out to the
jury those things that question whether
or not they've been able to prove the
case beyond reasonable doubt but i think
only time will tell in regards to that
yeah and they don't need to prove it but
motive seems to be a big question mark
in this case uh let's kind of talk about
the defense though matthew do you expect
a defense to put on witnesses could even
william hussell himself take the stand
in his own defense
well there are um you know six weeks of
the prosecution's case here we've heard
from witnesses uh nurses and doctors we
heard it from an expert for three days
last week as well as family members so
there's a lot of evidence out there
there's a lot for the jury to digest i
don't think this is the kind of case
where the defense says hey the
prosecution hasn't proved their case and
we're gonna we're gonna rest and we
don't have to do anything in this case i
think they do i think they want some
expert witness testimony there's some
controversy about who those witnesses
might be and we we might very well hear
from uh dr hussell because you know he
can explain why he did what he did yeah
maybe he has a non-criminal explanation
maybe this is just about getting a
second doctor's opinion as so many
people in this world do so we'll see how
this plays out when we come back the
trial of a former olympian we head to
new jersey for opening statements in the
attempted murder trial of michael
barrisson
[Music]
welcome back to long crime daily opening
statements are presented in the case of
olympic athlete michael barrison who
faces two counts of attempted murder all
this stems from the 2019 shooting of
lauren canarac a tenant and dressage
writer who worked with barisone leading
up to the shooting canorak and her
boyfriend robert goodwin lived on
barizone's property at the same time
barizone was training in canara in
dressage writing before the shooting a
string of 9-1-1 calls were made by both
parties barrissone saying he tried to
evict canarack and kamarak saying she
was being harassed barrisone was
arrested after he shot kanorak in the
chest and fired another shot at goodwin
as goodwin struggled with barristone
counteract called 9-1-1 she survived the
shooting and expected to testify on
monday prosecutors laid out the case to
the jury
when you go back to delivery and when
you go at you're asked to return a
verdict
it will not be about warren canary
it will not be about rob goodwin it will
not be about mary haskins it will not be
about any other person
except this man
this man the defendant is the one on
trial
so you may hear things that you don't
like about warren or rob or mary haskins
or any of these other people
but saying nasty things
misbehaving if you want to call it that
none of that is a justification
to get shot
none of it creates a necessity for that
person to be killed
no we're here on this trial because of
the defendant's choice on august 7 2019
his choice to get a gun a pink and black
nine millimeter handgun
to point that gun at lauren and pull the
trigger twice and then to turn it on rob
and pull the trigger again
during the defense's opening stamen
barrison himself broke down in tears
it's a tragedy
a tragedy
that lauren cataract was shot on that
day
that said there is another tragedy
a tragedy that will be played out in
this courtroom
the tragic
story of michael barrasso
an olympic athlete
a world-class versage trainer
a man who on the outside
appeared strong confident
in total control
but what the evidence will show
a much different picture
a man who had a horrible childhood was
physically abused by his mother sexually
molested by a neighbor over and over and
over again
the man who left home
to get away from all of that
and found solitude
security
in the equestrian
community matthew what was your reaction
to seeing barrisone break down during
his attorney's opening and how do you
think that will affect the jury
i don't want to be necessarily
necessarily cynical about it but but it
seems as though he started to break down
on cue um you know you know on the one
hand he he's a an accomplished olympic
athlete and coach on the other hand he's
an abused uh
down beaten uh individual and and he
you know seems to react to that uh
teary-eyed that you know
i don't know will that have an impact on
the jury you always want to tug at the
heartstrings of the jurors will that in
fact be something that that does impress
them um you know only time will tell
absolutely now julie what do you make of
these dueling 901 calls how's the jury
likely to interpret whether either side
was actually in danger
so it's always interesting to have one
9-1-1 call let alone have multiple 9-1-1
calls from both sides and i think when
you have multiple 9-1-1 calls
particularly these they do ignore to the
benefit i think of the defendant um
because any time there's a question the
jury has to say you know what beyond a
reasonable doubt means that the people
must prove the case not the defense and
one of the things that sticks out in the
9-1-1 call to me is the desperation
whether it's true or not of this
defendant in terms of begging the police
to get there begging them to come to try
to protect him and help him and that may
endure very well for him particularly
when the accusation is self-defense all
right we'll see how it plays out and
make sure to check out gavel to gamble
coverage of this the case with the law
and crime network well thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you